[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez comprendre comment hanouna de la
mondaine la faune billard corner il va
le sujet va très bien je suis en pleine
forme on est lundi c'est extraordinaire
ajouté parcours en trois jours j'étais
un peu triste
non pas du tout je forcerais jamais
personne avoir quelqu'un évidemment
j'étais triste mais en même temps juneau
vendredi soir exceptionnel dit soir à la
télé y avait trois prime avec de la
magie
sur ces huit là magie selon gainey mois
sur tf1 diversion et sur france 2 les
victoires de la musique avec daphné
bürki qui a fait disparaître tous les
téléspectateurs
j'en suis dit fais disparaître les stars
de la chanson puisque ma mère
connaissait absolument pas j'avais bu le
feuilleton gagner et c'est tout alors
y'a t il un joli bond jeunes enchaînent
dams au mondial n'est pas seulement on
embrasse quand même ma mère et ben ouais
c'est votre mère on peut prouver qu'on
pouvait pas faire revenir il monte en
l'air mais bon faire redescendre
commentaires des kouriles queen corner
57 avant de prendre 7 mai on embrasse
coco elle est avec les ctom et pourquoi
pas je pense moi mais c'est ensemble
qu'ils sont encore ensemble
enfin s'ils regardent j'en sais rien il
faudra foot doivent te regarde et je
suis sûr corinne et qui s'appelle
pendant ton frère patrick patrick et
corinne la mena ils ont des prénoms à
lens s'est classé lui ça toi ça dépasse
pas le nom mais sans et tu vois ta pas
on met ces mots tu vois c'est toi comme
moi dans ma famille en moi tu peux avoir
un jour mahmoud
[Rires]
vitu voix du ca des postes c'est patrick
qui va passer des prénoms très bien joué
walter qui est arrivé les embrasse en
tout cas une austérité regardent ils
doivent être fiers de toi écoute
j'espère en tout cas bien sûr vendredi
j'ai préféré regarder le prince de mon
ami maxime bien évidemment et comme
d'habitude s'irrite quand vous entrez
sur le prat le plateau en fin d'émission
on semble direct quel patron a rallié le
boss je dirais même plus qui est le
parrain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
apparu
vous êtes tellement le patron que vous
pouvez carrément ce pauvre maxime béni
pour reprendre votre place vous le
poussez ces manifs là c'est allé
[Musique]
elle touche à votre poste car c'est
vraiment le cas
maxime
la vérité est ce que j'ai pas eu des
mots très anti pour toi excellent même
voix la voix vous êtes patron c'est pas
du tout j'ai une émission à faire après
j'ai des ministres caraïbes et où tu
crois que j'ai faire le plein de magie
j'avais le numéro deux du gouvernement
qu'est ce que ça signifie
cette jeunesse là j'ai le gouvernement
là qui vient toutes les semaines sur ce
plateau bordel de merde et deux minutes
avant souhaité des baguettes dans le cul
c'est facile ce talent têtu magath dont
lyon comment tu expliques ça c'est bon
là alors c'est la troisième fois que
maxime derniers temps alors forcément
tout n'était pas parfait mais quand même
de grands moments sur discrétion les
quatre femmes sinon
niveau autorités maxime pianiste
stéphane bern personne ne les écoute
tout le monde s'en fout il faut voter
pour le meilleur magicien men origins se
servent à l'aide chinoise est apprécié à
huy jour de qingming bénigne à lons et
maxi gagner avec la longue on sait c'est
comme avec les meufs
ils n'y arrivent pas ici dans le coc
système tmp à présent on va passer à la
vitesse supérieure supérieur et je vous
présente la phrase la plus
incompréhensible de tous les temps à
battre est vif à votre visa va débuter
des baquets elle est encore ici
elle est peut-être dans les 60 à tim
daly quand il a lu millan embouteillages
de monde car il ya plein de mots qu
arrive t il faudrait mettre internet
avec un putois gbato toutefois par la
vitesse et la technique du tout raconter
une histoire
son mari voulait dire un truc tu as beau
avoir est je vous le dis un truc c'est
pas triste non excusez-moi je suis moi
d'intervenir
je parlerai plus crise à ces bonbons
aussi je ma vie alors on sait tous que
la 1ère fois que maxime gainey a trempé
son biscuit par la montre il était la
star de la série sous le point soleil
crois qu'il a trompé son biscuit quoi
lasser récent trois semaines deux
semaines
il ya des semaines dans mes rêves en
tout cas on a trouvé la tisane abalo de
la théière la dernière donnait alors pas
cher sa langue au chat
max et le célibataire le plus célèbre de
la télé en regardant sur prime j'ai
compris pourquoi ça ne marchait pas avec
les meufs à voici max le célibat tard
50 radio quand même nom 75 au monde a le
même âge tous les deux oui ouais quel
est votre secret de jouvence bernard tué
radieuse qui illumine le plateau à la
merci non pas ma part ta musique à mes
parents
alors évidemment on n'a pas une gosse
les pengouins non mais déjà quelques
années
votre compteur
oui qu'on passe à table a bien sûr
ecclésiale enfants c'est bien je vais
bien manche et ailleurs
mais non c'est toujours mignon ça part
toujours d'un bon sentiment quand il dit
que kelly vous aimez bien manger c'est
juste qui la connaît bien
expliques tu habites qui lie au
restaurant tu appelles le pel avant tout
à grigny sur la tête de ma mère à la
carte
à chaque fois qu'on est en reste aux
internautes si c'est tout on a déjà tout
prix là un truc tout fait sens réel
sarrassat non mais ça il pas alors et
alan nobu nouvelle à nous annoncer en
plus à un bon quoi se parait il pas et
j'ai entendu dire bonsoir mais ne sait
pas encore avec elle
il paraît qu'elle prépare l'été a à
présent témoigne paraît qu'elle prépare
les dykes apparemment va se mettre
beaucoup en manioc ouais ouais mais là
elle est très bien comme ça ok de son
mec dit la vérité
elle est très bien elle a perdu quelques
kilos elle est parfaite à medouneu
elle a perdu quelques kilos dans toute
sa carrière où la nappe a dernièrement
elle fait comme moi je mange des pommes
ouais c'est vrai je tremble c'est vous
une petite fringale offre une pomme et
c'est parfait un 100 m c'est là aussi il
y avait décroché pendant qu'on y est
numéro vert qui va s'afficher au bras
on nous appelle nous dit à quel moment
exactement vous avez décroché alors ses
rides quand vous n'êtes pas là il ya de
gros relâchement niveau riga à ce qu'on
l'a déjà dit ça ou pas alors je vous dis
la vérité sur twitter il ya plein de
gens qui ont dit ils se lâchent
complètement dans spy et moi j'adore
quand vous lâcher comme ça
alors certes il y en a un qui est très
très dissipée quand vous n'êtes pas là
c'est bernard montiel n'ont regardé mon
série halo monde va parler - maxime
pourrait l'utiliser pourtant isis
voilà d'or est-ce que vous avalez des
épées pas que déjà tellement lourd que
toute la soirée on entendu qu'un seul
prénom
bernard el fani cma kachine tabassé le
mois d'approchés vous approchez vous
avez des gaules rien avec la langue
bernard ton stylo regardez à quelle
place ils étaient assis été complètement
possédée par l'esprit de jean michel
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais pu choquer d'ailleurs voyages
propose tout de suite ou tard marine
peur pour les audiences wallon s'est
jamais non j'aime paquet à cartonne ta
chronique tu le sais bien mais coûte
super alors je continue parce que le
moment de foussignac lie alors assez
glauque six mois que j'arrive très bien
à 20h moi je quitte l'émission ça y
aller ou non mais tu veux que j'appelle
corinne et patrick haulot vendredi bien
entendu balances ton post on regarde ça
tout le temps c'est la nouvelle
référence des émissions infotainment tu
vois c'est cet homme que je veux dire
alors j'adore évidemment l'émission mais
des fois je fatigue un peu
alors je fais des micro sieste et
vendredi ça a provoqué une situation
assez cocasse comme dirait maxime à
23h03 tout va bien vous êtes à côté du
numéro deux du gouvernement françois de
rugy
je ne pense pas que le président de
l'appuyer coup le pré ministre soit pour
ce genre de découpe car attendait et le
président a écrit dans sa lettre il ré
parler du vote obligatoire du vote blanc
gap a dit je veux le vote obligatoire
jouer le vote blanc mélanie discutons et
soudain je me réveille à 1h 46 et vous
êtes à côté de cette personne
merci merci ca me parait la personne
certaines sinon je vois pas du tout
alors un des thèmes principaux vent du
changement c'est là c'était la chirurgie
esthétique
on aurait pu croire que c'était une
spéciale sosies justement parce que
vendu on avait on avait le sosie de ken
bien sûr ah ouais on avait on avait le
sosie de nana mouskouri
évidemment on avait également le sosie
de robert de niro et sony de mabina ah
ouais j'en avais aussi le sosie de roger
lecointe d'affiner spieser avec c'est
roger qu'on embrasse le petit copain de
delphine wespiser petits copains se
passe ça ne veut pas né comme j'ai
décidé de lancer une nouvelle séquence
pour ceux qui n'auraient pas pu voir les
victimes vendredi
ça s'appelle résume-t-on poste il vous
allez voir notamment la preuve que
encore une fois mal on se repose soucier
l'émission qui traite tout le temps de
grave sujet politique tarbes a signalé
subi aucune paix nos plats fils et d'un
agrandissement du pénis c'est ça dans le
cadre des donc vous attendent à mener
vous étiez avec un chirurgien effet on
l'a de la gare sont au chômage alors
vous avez d'intervenants qui sont très
sympathiques mais qui peuvent pas vous
plairait comment on devient docteur en
sciences de l'environnement
eh ben vous fait des chinois hans en
environnement je pourrais vous parler un
peu plus de monde aux primaires
a déjà bonjour à tous servent à ça donc
moi je suis venu ici tout le monde s'en
fout même karim zéribi vous écoute même
plus et riche pays à quelques personnes
il doit vous arriver quelqu'un non
politique tonne la société a pas que les
gens ou des mères des petits maires qui
ne veulent pas se représenter
alors vous avez décidé de faire la
gueule à karim zéribi fait quelque chose
qui donne envie il faut donner envie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le meilleur moment des nations eric
naulleau va faire une vanne et françois
de rugy va pas qui fait du tout regarder
ça de l'internement et le chef de l'état
se servent de l'écologie parce que ça
fait bien
bon allez taper au portefeuille une fois
passée la voir aussi danser un peu fait
entuber
[Applaudissements]
pour finir vendredi vous receviez michel
montagut c'est le président et
cofondateur de coop food
ah oui bien sûr été là michel mais là
est ce que vous avez remarqué que quand
il parlait il sortait sa longue date
dans une tpe comme ça alors regardons ça
bouge de plus près vous ailleurs j'ai un
truc hallucinant et vous allez voir ce
petit magnéto c'est cette incroyable
rayon de compte et non faire sur salon
et comme il est très détendue la soeur
de plus en plus et qui vont aller
expliqué avant de mettre une amende
s'ils n'ont pas dit non expliqué
d'accord il ya 13 millions de personnes
sont en précarité alimentaire
il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui est correct
alimentaire d'un côté et arrêtons ce
soir
[Applaudissements]